with his supporters backing him at every
step he done everything to try and avoid
this
but as his motorcade swept through
Jerusalem's cleared streets the moment
had finally confronted Benjamin
Netanyahu the man they call the king of
Israel arrived in court for the start of
an historic day for this country a
sitting Prime Minister on trial for
corruption inside the building but
before entering the court itself there
was a trademark defiance rule Moomba mr.
Bob Buckley booth elements in police and
the general attorney's office have
allied with left-wing media I called him
that just not Bibi gang in order to
stitch up and found it and alissa me
three cases against me the objective is
to topple a strong right-wing Prime
Minister and then it was into the room
to the defendants bench and away from
the cameras to hear the charges against
him the trial centers around three cases
case 1000 in which he said to have
received a continuous supply of
champagne and cigars from two
businessman in return it said he acted
for the benefit of one of the
businessman case 2000 involves positive
coverage from a media tycoon in return
it's alleged mr. Netanyahu offered to
restrict the circulation or a rival
paper and case 4000 the most serious
it's alleged that he promoted regulatory
decisions that favored a telecoms
company inside that they are just as
defiance out here as he is in there
justice and everything will be okay
Netanyahu wants to be like the president
in France who was immune from
prosecution like the Queen of England
who can't be prosecuted and many other
ahead to say he wants to be treated like
them and he he's affronted by the fact
that he has to appear in court and he'll
do everything possible to try and put on
trial instead of him the Israeli legal
system which had the temerity to put him
on trial but in doing that by blaming
the legal system the media and the
liberal left his critics say he is
dangerously undermining faith in
Israel's democratic institutions Bibi as
he's known has been written off many
times but his survival is extraordinary
three years of investigations three
separate cases and three elections and
he is still Prime Minister he says his
head will be held high and he'll
continue to lead the country and fight a
case that could last several years
mark stone Sky News in Jerusalem
[Music]